if I'm dating you we're dating for six
months seven eight yeah okay and you ask
me no first of all there's another
energy that we do you see a lot of times
of men we don't have to
arm of a lot of trauma and it and it
comes out in a way to interact with men
you can feel it the room can feel it the
energy it is so when we feel this we
know so we already know this is not
gonna be a long-term thing but then
there's other ones you can't necessarily
and you're like you're gonna give the
girl the one opportunity and I said I
want to feel like Carnage this the
reason I say I want to feel like corn is
because when Kanye married Kim he knew
exactly what he was getting into this is
why I don't if you cry if he's crying
now you're crying what are you crying
for bro you know what he's doing yeah so
that means that he could not step into a
room and he did not know nothing about
about her so no one could come and
embarrass her a lot what a lot of girls
do is they like a guy and then they
don't want to tell the full truth so
they start the relationship built upon a
lie